J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK, we're
still talking about
addition to alkenes.
And we've looked at these
various electrophile cum
nucleophiles adding to alkenes.
And now, at the beginning last
time, we introduced the idea
of osmium tetroxide and we'll go
on to permanganate as
reagents for dihydroxylation of
alkenes.
Then we'll go onto things
involving transition metals,
catalytic hydrogenation, and
also metathesis and catalyzed
polymerization.
So last time, we looked at the
end at OsO4, which looked a
little bit like O3 and could do
the same trick O3 could do,
to give this osmate ester, which
is like an acetal.
So it's possible to add water
and get the osmium equivalent
of a carbonyl group, and the two
hydroxyl groups added to
the termini of the alkene.
So the problem with this is OsO4
is a very efficient
reagent for that, but it's
poisonous, and
it's also very expensive.
So you have to figure out some
way not to use so much of it.
And the way you could do it is
to use just a little bit of it
as a catalyst, and put hydrogen
peroxide in there, in
order to convert the osmium
equivalent of trioxide back to
the tetroxide again, so it can
cycle around and keep doing
the reaction.
In fact, it was improved in
1976, by using a different
oxidizing agent, this N-oxide,
the morpholine oxide.
And in fact, this is called the
Upjohn process, which is
relevant because the guy whose
picture is over here, whose
estate gave the money for
redoing this room awhile back,
was the research director at
Upjohn Laboratories.
So anyhow, that was a good way
to do it.
But then, we should notice
something about the
stereochemistry of this.
We showed here a trans-2-butene.
And of course, if it's like
ozone, the two oxygens will
add at the same time, therefore
to the same face.
So the configuration you get at
the two carbons, where the
OH's add, are related to one
another.
They could be S, S, as shown
here.
Of course, the osmium tetroxide
could equally well
have come in from the bottom, or
the 2-butene could have
been turned over, and then you
would have gotten R, R. So of
course you don't get chirality
without
starting with chirality.
That is, a single chirality.
However, you can start with it
in a ligand that attaches to
the to the osmium.
So if you use a chiral amine
ligand, then, you only get one
of the two enantiomers of the
dihydroxylated alkene.
And this, you won't be surprised
to hear, was also
invented by Professor Sharpless,
whom we talked about
last semester with respect to
adding oxygen.
And so this is called the
Sharpless asymmetric
dihydroxylation.
He invented it in 1988, and I
think this room was the first
place he talked about it in
public.
He was standing right there, and
in fact, he did a
demonstration on this table, as
I'm going to do in the end.
But I'm going to do a different
demonstration.
Because osmium tetroxide which
he used, is very
dangerous and poisonous.
And he actually spilled it on
this table.
I think it's now long gone,
since that was 1988.
But at least what I'm going to
do just uses vinegar, so you
don't have to worry about that.
OK, so anyhow, here's a specific
example of using
Sharpless asymmetric
dihydroxylation with that
diene. It gives a 97% enantiomer
excess of the
indicated configuration here.
Now, the permanganate is much
cheaper, and looks very much
like osmium tetroxide, so it
won't surprise you that it
also can do this trick.
And here, you get 85% yield with
cyclohexene.
And again, it's a syn addition,
the two OH's come in
on the same face.
But that's not one where there's
a catalyst that'll
make it give only one
enantiomer.
Now on to catalytic
hydrogenation.
So we looked before at the idea
of drawing two curved
arrows and making H2 add to an
alkene.
And saw that the orbitals
weren't set up for that.
HOMO wouldn't match HOMO, LUMO
with LUMO, so there's no
profit in that.
However, we said, even though
that doesn't work, that it
does work if you have a metal
catalyst, like palladium or
platinum, or many other
transition metals.
So let's look a little bit at
how it is that palladium does
this trick.
It does it by providing orbital
variety.
Rather than just having the
orbitals that we showed
before, the sigma and sigma-star
of the H-H bond,
and the pi and pi-star of the
alkene, you have lots of
different shapes of orbitals on
the metal.
For example, in ethylene, we
have the pi, and the pi-star,
but in the metal, palladium has
4d10, 5s0, and 5p0.
So the occupied orbitals of
palladium,
then, are this dz squared.
Now, is that set up to overlap
well with pi-star?
The HOMO below and the LUMO
above?
What do you think, is that going
to be a good reaction?
Who's got an opinion, Karl?
STUDENT: I don't think so
because how you have the red
on one side of the blue and on
the other side of the blue you
might be able to get one side of
the red to overlap?
PROFESSOR: Maybe on one side,
but not as shown there.
Right?
That's what you're saying there?
And you're right, they're
orthogonal as drawn.
But there are other d orbitals.
There are five of these d
orbitals, so we could check
out others.
How about the dyz, is that going
to do the trick?
Are you going to get overlap if
you bring that up?
Kate, what do you say?
If you turned it, you
could...
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: but as shown, it's
orthogonal.
Right?
OK, how about that one?
Is that going to do the trick?
No?
Chris is shaking his head.
That won't do it.
How about that one?
No?
It's still that one of them is
symmetrical right to left, the
other is antisymmetric right to
left, so
they'd have no overlap.
How about that one?
Ah, just right.
OK, so that one can come up and
overlap, and stabilize the
electrons that were on the
metal.
And that new orbital shown there
is, in
fact, the HOMO-4.
It's gotten quite stable, right?
In fact, part of the reason it
got stable is the nature of
the orbitals changes as atoms
come up, and
the geometry changes.
So although it looks very much
like those two original
orbitals, and in a sense, came
from them, by the time it gets
to this point at the complex,
it's 40% of that dxy orbital
on the bottom.
47%, actually, on the top is
sigma C-H's, but 13% is still
the pi-star.
So that's just to tell you the
ugly truth.
But the fact is that the
reaction began, and went
through a transition state
because of the
mixing of those orbitals.
So that's two electrons.
But how about the other way
around?
How about if we use the HOMO on
the top?
Now, of course, we have all
these d orbitals on the
bottom, and few of them would
overlap, and even that one
which does overlap you don't
care about, because
it's HOMO with HOMO.
We want unoccupied orbitals on
the bottom, which
means that 5s and 5p.
So there's the 5p.
That's an unoccupied orbital,
that's going to overlap well,
and there's the 5s.
It'll overlap.
So you use some mixture of those
two.
You'll use a hybrid orbital.
An sp hybrid of some sort on the
palladium, which will
overlap with that HOMO and
stabilize another pair of
electrons.
And there it is in the complex.
You see, it's a hybrid orbital
below, and the pi orbital
above, forming that new bond,
stabilizing those electrons.
In fact, if you look at the ugly
truth on this one, by the
time you get to the complex,
it's changed.
It's 67% of pi, and it's 11% of
an sp hybrid.
But it's also 15% of that d
orbital that we showed at the
beginning, so things have gotten
mixed up.
But that's the way it happened,
because you had
these vacant orbitals that could
overlap from below on
the metal, overlap with pi, you
had the filled orbital,
the particular one, the orbital
that could overlap
with pi-star.
So you stabilize two pairs of
electrons.
That means you make two new
bonds to the alkene.
So the palladium, or platinum,
or many of these transition
metals can do this trick of
adding two at the same time to
the alkene.
Now you can also do it to sigma
bonds.
So here's palladium reacting
with H2.
It's just sigma and sigma-star
now.
But if that's the energy of the
starting material in a
pretty crummy calculation, so
don't hang your hat on this,
these are successive stages as
you go left to right.
First, you begin to associate
the H2 with the palladium, and
bond to it.
Then the H2 gets even closer,
and as it gets closer and
closer, the hydrogens spread
apart.
And the reason I've drawn them
up and down a little bit is to
show energy minima and
transition states.
So first, you get the H2
associated with palladium,
without very close contact.
Then it gets closer, and goes
over a transition state, and
becomes this one, which is
closer bonded.
And then, the two hydrogens come
apart, and
get quite far apart.
But notice, at least in this
calculation, and in some
others, as you'll see, it goes
up hill a little bit.
So that would seem to be
unfavorable.
You could do it, you could split
the hydrogen apart on
the metal, but in terms of
enthalpy, kilocalories per
mole, it's uphill.
However, once it gets up there,
these hydrogens can
move from one metal to the next,
because we're talking a
solid metal, in this case.
So in fact, it dissociates on
the palladium surface, and
then the hydrides move.
So you get an advantage from
entropy, from the hydrogens
getting apart, even though it's
uphill a
little bit in energy.
It's very favorable to move them
apart in entropy, rather
than having to have them right
next to one another.
So it's possible to dissociate
hydrogen on palladium.
Now here's a calculation
certainly better than the
previous one.
It was published in the Journal
of Physical
Chemistry in 2004.
And it shows the same thing,
palladium approaching hydrogen
above, palladium approaching
methane below.
And again, I don't think that
these are great numbers,
probably, but it gives you the
idea of what I showed on the
previous slide, and some
specific geometries.
OK, now, catalytic hydrogenation
puts these two
reactions together that we just
looked at.
You have what inorganic chemists
call "oxidative addition."
That's where we do this, which
we just saw is possible, two
electrons can get stabilized
because of the orbitals that
are available, to form something
like a
three-member ring here.
And that's called oxidative
addition.
The reason it's called oxidative
is the way inorganic
chemists count electrons.
They say that if you have a bond
to metal, those electrons
belong to the ligand, not to the
metal.
So electrons, formally, have
been taken
away from the metal.
We'll talk more about oxidation
and
reduction before too long.
But anyhow, that's called
oxidative addition.
But of course, you could do the
reverse, as well.
You could do reductive
elimination, and pull the
alkene back off again.
OK, now you do the same thing
with hydrogen, as we just saw.
So you could have oxidative
addition, those two arrows
move like that, to give that,
and then the blue reverse, the
reductive elimination, and
you're back where you started.
But now, suppose you do both of
these things.
Let's suppose that we first do
the oxidative addition, the
insertion of palladium into the
H-H bond, and one of the
H's, let's say, moves away.
And now we have room on the
surface of the palladium,
there, to bring in the alkene
and do its trick.
So now, we have this form.
Now of course, you could do
reductive elimination again.
Now incidentally, in that form,
the experts discuss just
how much the different bonds are
formed.
Sometimes they draw it this way,
and just say the alkene
is complexed.
But that begs the question of
what is it that's holding the
alkene there, and it's those
orbital interactions
that we looked at.
The electrons going one way, the
electrons going the other.
So we'll for our purposes of our
lecture today, we'll say
that the bonds are completely
formed, even though
they may not be.
OK, so you can do reductive
elimination, it
could come off again.
But suppose you did the other
reductive elimination?
Suppose you did that one?
Now you're over here.
And you've put hydrogen on one
carbon, and
palladium on the other.
Now suppose we have that
hydrogen that's wandering
around the surface, suppose we
bring it back?
Can you see what I'm going to do
now?
Chris, do you have an idea of
what step is next?
Look at the title of the slide.
STUDENT: We might hydrogenate?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we want to put
a hydrogen on each of the
carbons, how are we going to do
that?
We've got a hydrogen on the
right carbon already, how do
we get a hydrogen on the left
carbon?
STUDENT: We have a hydrogen
nearby, that's
bonded to the palladium.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and the carbon
is bonded to palladium.
And what will we call the
process that gets the hydrogen
bonded to carbon, instead of the
carbon and the hydrogen
bonded to palladium?
STUDENT: Substitution?
PROFESSOR: Nope.
It's that.
Anybody got a name for that?
That's the reductive
elimination, the blue thing
we've been talking about, all
these, right?
They come on, they come off,
they come on, they come off.
But if you put them on one way,
and take them off a
different way, you've done the
trick.
Got it?
OK.
Now, notice, that that addition
of the palladium, the
oxidative addition of alkene to
palladium, happened two at
the same time, so they come in
on the same face.
It's a syn addition.
And then, when the hydrogens
replace palladium, they come
in on the front side.
It's not a backside attack.
When we curve those two arrows,
it's
not attacking backside.
So, they come in from the same
side as well, so the overall
product is syn addition.
The H's came in on the same--
here, the bottom face of the
double bond.
And of course, if you put methyl
groups on there, and it
were 2-butene, then you'd expect
to get that particular
isomer of the 2-butene, where
the two hydrogens operated,
added on same side.
Of course, you couldn't tell it,
because the other two
things would be hydrogens as
well.
How could you tell?
How could you tell that the two
came in on the same side?
PROFESSOR: You wouldn't you use
hydrogen,
what would you use?
STUDENT: Deuterium.
PROFESSOR: You'd use deuterium,
as you say.
Yeah, so then you could tell.
And here's an example, from the
book, where they use
deuterium and platinum oxide, in
this case, and the two D's
came in on the same side.
That was not necessary, in this
case, to tell, because
you also have the cyclohexane
ring there.
So, it says here that deuterium
is
added in a syn fashion.
It's a syn addition.
And here's a typical passage
from another textbook, the
Loudon textbook that we used
several years ago, about
stereochemistry of this addition
reaction, catalytic
hydrogenation.
And it says, "stereospecific
syn-addition" happens, it
says, for "most alkenes." And it
gives this example.
But I'm actually doing this
little bit to show you how to
read text books.
So it says, most alkenes do
this, and give stereospecific
syn-addition, and it gives an
example.
But notice, it doesn't say what
the yield is.
It could be one of these
things-- remember last time,
we said there was a 55:45, that
was said to be specific,
or to favor one over the other.
So it doesn't say what the yield
is.
And it doesn't give any
reference to the literature
where you could look up and see
what they yield was, or
how they did it, or how much of
the other isomer there
might have been there.
Now this is very typical for
textbooks, and I have no doubt
that this happens with high
specificity, in this case.
But on the other hand, you
shouldn't be
satisfied with that.
So you would look in another
book, like this book from 1972
by House, Modern Synthetic
Chemistry.
Now this is a graduate-level
text.
So it shows an example, here,
using palladium on carbon as
the catalyst. Palladium on
carbon means you have
palladium metal, but you don't
want to have a big chunk of
metal, because there's not much
surface.
So you want it to be very finely
divided, but you want
to be able to handle it.
You don't have very much, so you
put it on charcoal.
It's absorbed on the surface of
the charcoal.
So that's what palladium on
carbon is.
So it's done in acetic acid,
with hydrogen gas at one
atmosphere, and you have that
double bond.
And what do you would notice
about the stereochemistry of
the product?
Is it a syn addition?
Which is the product of syn
addition?
Sebastian?
The one on the left or the
right?
STUDENT: The one on the left.
PROFESSOR: The one on the left.
The two came in on the same
side.
On the right, one came in on the
top, one on the bottom.
And 90% of the product is the
wrong one, the one the book
tells you, or almost any book
will tell
you, is a syn addition.
And it often is.
Now, look at this example from
1948.
What's going on here?
This is Barton in 1948.
Anybody else remember what
Barton was talking about in
1948 or '49, from last semester?
That was the first
conformational analysis.
And it was molecules very like
this.
So this is what he was working
on, these steroids.
But notice these two compounds
are allylic isomers.
They only differ in the position
of that double bond.
There are three carbons in a
row, and a double bond between
two of them.
That's an allylic system.
So these are isomers where you
move a hydrogen from the top
to the bottom, and now you have
a double bond here and a
single bond here.
So those are allylic isomers.
And now if you look at the
details of this primary
literature, it says that there's
a rearrangement of one
of these compounds to the other,
right?
And it says that it happens in
80% yield.
80% of the product has gone from
here to here.
Now, this is what you would use
for catalytic
hydrogenation.
But instead of hydrogenating, it
first went by allylic
rearrangement.
Now, how did that happen?
So let's look back again at the
mechanism of the catalytic
hydrogenation.
First, you have the oxidative
addition of the double bond,
and then you have the reductive
elimination, on the
right, to put the first hydrogen
on.
And then you put the other
hydrogen on
the left, and continue.
Of course that reaction would be
reversible.
You could have taken this back
off again, in the wrong way,
and instead of going there,
pardon me, you could go there.
But the other thing you could
have done is, if there's an
allylic hydrogen in the compound
you're talking about,
so not only the alkene, but the
next door carbon has a
hydrogen on it, you're here,
you're here, you're here,
you're here, you get to there.
OK?
And now, one possibility is to
reverse that way.
That's the reductive
elimination, or pardon me,
oxidative addition that takes
you back here, that undoes
those blue arrows, and would
take you back.
But what other option is there?
Can anybody see another option?
Liang?
STUDENT: The other side.
PROFESSOR: Aha, that compound is
symmetric, if you have an
allylic hydrogen.
So it could unzip that way, too.
And now, instead of going back
to this, you go back to this.
And if that does the reductive
elimination,
you come back here.
And now, you'll notice that has
isomerized the alkene.
The double bond moved next door.
So it's all these oxidative
addition reductive
eliminations, but if you go
through that symmetric
intermediate, then you can take
the wrong one off as you
go back toward starting
material.
So the starting material is
actually isomerized product.
So that's presumably how it
happens.
So catalytic hydrogenation can
lead to allylic rearrangement.
And now let's go back and look
at that paper.
And we see that if we had that
rearrangement, this could go
to this, in fact, it could go to
four different isomers.
It could be the double bond
here, or
here, or here, or here.
So we could come back to this.
And now, once you're here, if
you add hydrogen, even if you
add them from the same side,
those two hydrogens, they
could be the opposite side from
where the
first hydrogen was.
So now you could expect to get
this, and you'd expect more of
this than this, because that
form is more stable.
It's conformationally a better
structure.
OK, so 90% there.
Now, the nice thing is you don't
have to even look at the
secondary literature, you go
back to the primary
literature, because it gives a
reference here.
So we can look at that
reference, and see here where
they give the table about
studying these things.
And down here, in row 7, you see
they're talking about
compound VII, delta-9,10-octalin
So the ring
is numbered in a certain way,
and that double bond is
between nine and ten.
Now, if they started with that
material, you see they got 90%
of the trans product.
That's this one, that's what
shown here: 90%, 10%.
But if they did only partial
hydrogenation, they still got
90% of this, but they had 100%--
after doing 80% of the
hydrogenation.
It says down here they did it
80%.
After doing that, they don't
have any of this stuff.
It's all this stuff.
So if these things can go back
and forth, it must be that the
equilibrium lies in this
direction.
And occasionally, when you get
over here, you
go on to the product.
And that's the explanation of
it.
But it's interesting to look
even a little closer, to look
at what happened if they started
with VIII.
So suppose they start with VIII.
If you start at VII, and you can
go through VIII to get
down here, you get 90% of the
product.
That's their explanation.
Suppose you start with pure
VIII.
What should you get?
In terms of the product.
If you didn't have VII, if you
start with VIII.
Debby, you got an idea?
STUDENT: Wouldn't you get the
one below?
PROFESSOR: You should get at
least this much, maybe more.
Right?
If the way you get here-- if
some of it goes this way, and
you start here and get 10 to
90, if you start here, you
should get even
more than 90 to 10.
Because you don't have the
chance
of going here initially.
Got it?
OK, what does it say?
You get 80%.
So there's something rotten
here, but no one's ever
talked about it.
It could be just that the
experiments weren't done
really carefully, or maybe the
catalyst was a little bit
different in one case than the
other.
I don't know what the answer is.
But it's when you go back to dig
in to where the real
results are that you find things
that are interesting.
So evidently, this isn't 100%
understood.
But I have no doubt that this
allylic rearrangement is a big
source of getting what appears
to be the wrong addition.
that it really is syn addition,
but it happens after
you've rearranged things.
So the product isn't what you
would have expected, naively.
OK, now, a process called
metathesis of an alkene.
This was reported when I first
came here to Yale, the first
year I was here, and it was
amazing.
People were amazed by this
reaction.
And the mechanism was quite
speculative.
Nobody had any idea what
happened at the beginning.
But in the subsequent whatever
number of years, 45 years,
it's been figured out.
And what is involved is a double
bond from
the metal to carbon.
Of course, there are there two
other things on the carbon.
But this is called an alkylidene
complex.
And in fact, this process was
the basis for the Nobel Prize
in 2005, which went to Grubbs.
So this is a metal alkylidene
complex.
We can come in with an alkene,
and do the oxidative addition,
to form that, and a reductive
elimination.
So it gives a metalla-
cyclobutane
a cyclobutane that has a metal
in it.
Just by the same processes we
talked about on
the previous slide.
Now, those processes are
reversible.
And what do you notice about
reversing it?
Liang?
What about the intermediate
here?
STUDENT: It's symmetrical.
PROFESSOR: It's symmetrical.
So you can reverse the other
direction, to go to there, and
then that can come apart.
And you've put the central
carbon, the one that's here,
changed it from being attached
to this carbon to being
attached to this carbon.
So you can take, effectively,
two alkenes, and mix up their
carbons, which is double- bonded
to which.
Now, you've heard of Professor
Ziegler, who last semester
taught the other organic course.
I don't know if you've seen him
around in the lab, maybe.
He's unusually tall, he's 6' 6",
or something like that.
And I point out, here, that he's
not
Professor Karl Ziegler.
We'll talk about Professor Karl
Ziegler
a few slides later.
But he was visiting Japan, in
1986, and this delegation of
junior high girls thought he was
so tall, they should get
their picture taken with him,
which is here.
But he wasn't the only tall guy
visiting
Japan at that time.
Here he is, touring together
with Professor Grubbs, the guy
that got the Nobel Prize in
2005, who's equally tall.
In fact, Professor Grubbs's
daughter played
basketball at Yale.
She's quite tall.
I think she holds the rebounding
record for women's
basketball at Yale.
So this'll help you remember
Professor Grubbs, I hope.
In fact, they took another
picture together with their
host, Professor Murahashi.
So again, I underline that
they're unusually tall people.
OK, but Grubbs invented a
process called ROMP:
ring-opening metathesis
polymerization.
Now here's a double bond where
both of the carbons in the
double bond are part of the same
molecule, I mean, the
same framework.
So if you cleave that double
bond, and exchange partners
with something else, you still
have the two linked together
through this other ring.
So if you bring in this
alkylidene compound, and do
the trick of metathesis, you get
that.
And now the product is still an
alkylidene ruthenium here,
so you can do that with another
one of these molecules.
In fact, you can do with the n
of the molecules, and they'll
all link together in a chain
like this, to give a polymer.
So this ring opening metathesis
was a very
important part of this Nobel
Prize work
to generate a polymer.
OK, now catalytic hydrogenation,
we
saw, looked like this.
But Ziegler-Natta
polymerization, this is the
other Ziegler, Karl Ziegler, a
German, looks very similar.
So it has titanium, with an R
group on it.
An alkene comes in, oxidative
addition, to give this.
Reductive elimination, on the
other side gives that.
But now, that we could just call
a different R group.
It's not the original R group,
it's the R group with two
carbons in between, that we just
brought in.
Now what can you do?
You can bring it back to start
over again, right?
And that'll be the R, and then
you bring it in, and that's
the R. And then you do it again,
and again, and again,
and you can make a very long
chain of ethylene molecules,
for example.
Now, Ziegler found this--
I contacted Grubbs, yesterday,
in order to get permission to
show his picture to you, and
Murahashi as well, and
Ziegler, incidentally.
But he told me an interesting
story of how Ziegler
discovered this.
It was during the second World
War, and in Germany they were
short of lubricating oil.
So he was trying to figure out
how to use triethyl aluminum
to add to alkenes, and then
polymerize on the basis of
that to get things that could be
lubricating oils.
And after the war, he continued
that work, but
sometimes they found different
products, rather than these
oils they were trying to make.
And they traced it to the
presence of
metals in the reactor.
So then they tried all different
salts, and when they
used titanium tetrachloride,
they found that they had made
a heterogeneous catalyst for
polymerization, the thing that
I've shown here.
Now I underline that this is
heterogeneous.
You mix these things together,
it's a witch's brew, and
nobody knows, really, exactly
what's in there.
And the reason you don't know is
because it's a solid.
It's not a pure crystalline
compound, it's not something
in solution that you could do
spectroscopy on to figure out
exactly what it is.
So it's very hard to study
mechanism with these
heterogeneous catalysts.
But that doesn't mean they're
not useful.
For example, high density
polyethylene, the number two
of your recycling thing, with ns
of from 800 to a quarter
million chain lengths, was made
in 2004 to the tune of 25
times 10 to the sixth tons, 25
million tons.
Or polypropylene, with up to 10
to the 5 units in a chain,
again, 45 million tons in 2007.
So this Ziegler-Natta catalyst
was a really revolutionary
thing for making polymers.
But it was hard to do the
mechanisms.
Now, one thing that we'll see
later, that free radicals also
can polymerize things, can
polymerize alkenes.
But a difference here is that
these are isotactic, that you
get from Ziegler-Natta
polymerization.
So I should tell you what
tacticity is.
So if you have a polymer chain,
and the alkenes had,
say, methyl groups on them,
propylene instead of ethylene,
then you have a bunch of
stereocenters.
Now, notice that every alkene
went in head to tail, that is,
CH2 then CH, CH2, CHCH3, CH2,
CHCH3.
CH2, CH, CH3.
So it's head to tail, but it's
stereoregular.
All the methyls are coming out
that you.
And that's called isotactic.
An alternative would be all head
to tail
but syndiotactic: out, back,
out, back, out,
back, every other one.
And of course it could be
random.
Out and back.
So there are these three
different fundamental types of
polymers: isotactic,
syndiotactic, and atactic.
And they have different
properties, and we'll talk
about polymer properties in the
next lecture, and why they
should be different.
So for some purposes you'd want
one, for some another.
Now there are two questions that
we'll address here.
One is, how do you know which is
which?
How do you know whether you have
an isotactic or a
syndiotactic or atactic.
And for that, you've got to wait
until we get to NMR, it's
coming very soon.
It's a really neat way to figure
out which is which.
But a more fundamental question
is, how do you
control what you make?
So there are these catalysts,
instead of using titanium, use
these zirconium catalysts, which
are homogeneous.
That means they're dissolved
they're not some solid that's
in there. So it's possible to do
spectroscopy on these things.
And Kaminsky, the name
associated with this
catalysis, has to do with his
accidental discovery that
adding MAO makes these very
reactive.
MAO is methylaluminoxane, which
is a sophisticated name
for something that nobody knows
what it is.
You mix stuff together and you
get that, and it's
not always the same.
But if you add it to the
zirconium dichloride
complexes, you get a very active
catalyst. So there have
been, I think, since this was
discovered in 1980, there have
been something like 7,000 papers
written on it, or
something like that, and 2,000
patents.
Now one thing that's pretty much
agreed on is that what
this methylaluminoxane takes the
chlorides off, puts an R
group like methyl on the
zirconium, and
leaves it as a cation.
Now, what happens next?
The alkenes approach, but they
approach from alternate faces.
Let's see what that means.
So here we take propylene, and
bring it into the front to
make one of these complexes.
And then the R group shifts
across, and you make a bond.
Have you ever seen a reaction
like that, where you have a
metal with a group attached to
it, alkene comes up, and you
form a bond here and this thing
comes over?
The BH, hydroboration, is
exactly that
same kind of thing.
So we'll call that new group R
prime.
The original one was R .
But now the next alkene comes in
and associates with the
zirconium, but what's different
from
the first one I drew?
It's now in the back.
The first alkene came in in the
front.
So it goes in the back, now the
R prime moves back there,
and then the next alkene comes
in in front.
And it comes over there.
And so on, and so on.
And you build a long chain.
But notice, every other one is
reacting in front, in back, in
front, in back.
Now let's compare the front and
back of
this zirconium complex.
Notice it has an axis of
symmetry there.
If you rotate 180 degrees about
that axis of symmetry,
you get the same thing again.
So the front and the back are
superimposable.
They look just the same.
So whatever happens in front
with respect to
stereochemistry will happen the
same way in back.
So the two faces, front and
back, are homotopic, they're
the same, so you'll get the same
chemistry, the same
stereochemistry, at either one.
Now how is it different in this
case? That instead of
having an axis of symmetry has a
mirror plane of symmetry.
What does that mean about the
front and the back?
Sebastian?
What do you say?
What's the relationship between
the
front and the back?
Are they superimposable?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: So what would you
call them?
STUDENT: Enantiotopic
PROFESSOR: Right, so those are
enantiotopic.
So whatever the one's face does,
the other one will do
the opposite.
And as you bounce back and
forth, what product are you
going to get now?
STUDENT: Syndiotactic
PROFESSOR: It'll be
syndiotactic.
And now suppose you take this
one, which has a horizontal
plane, which means the top and
the bottom are both
accessible.
On the front, you can go either
to the top or to the
bottom, equally.
So there's no selection.
So what do you think you're
going to get now?
If it doesn't make any
difference which way you go.
Now the faces are achiral, and
you get an atactic product.
So you can control which one you
get by choosing the
symmetry of the ligand that's
attached to the zirconium.
Now as I said, as I promised,
you can also do free-radical
polymerization.
I said we'd discuss that.
This was the earliest kind of
polymerization studied in
laboratories.
So alkene comes in, bingo.
Another one, bingo.
Bingo.
So we're growing a long chain.
But the difference is that in
this case, you can get
rotation around this bond to get
that form.
And when you do, that radical is
close to this hydrogen.
And you can go from a primary
radical
to a secondary radical.
That's downhill.
And now you can add an alkene to
that.
So if you do radical
polymerization, as opposed to
doing these metal-catalyzed
polymerizations, you can get
branches, you get occasional
butyl chains, C4 chains, stuck
on your long chain.
And that means that they don't
pack together as efficiently,
so it's not as crystalline.
So since it doesn't pack as
well, it's not as dense.
So that gives low density
polyethylene, the kind of
stuff that you get in dry
cleaner bags, the flimsy
stuff, as opposed to what you
would get in a supermarket
to carry groceries in, which is
tougher, and opaque.
Now let's look at it again.
We start polymerization going,
fine, free-radical
polymerization.
But, we may not want it to keep
going, because properties
of the polymer, like its
viscosity, its melting point,
depend on how long the chain is.
We may want to control how long
the chain is.
How could we control the length
of the chain?
One way to control the polymer
chain length is to add a
molecule, like carbon
tetrachloride.
There are many such reagents,
not just carbon
tetrachloride.
OK, now, the radical can attack
the
chlorine, like this.
And now you have a
trichloromethyl radical, and
your chain is done.
But, you have the
trichloromethyl radical. So it
can add to another alkene.
And then that one can grow a new
chain.
So you see, what you've done by
this is used what's called
a chain-transfer agent.
It doesn't destroy the kinetic
chain. The radical still keeps
working, but on a new molecule.
So you shorten the polymer
molecules without terminating
the chain reaction.
So if you add more of the chain-
transfer agent, you get
shorter chains.
So if you measure the rate of
the transfer, the reaction
with the carbon tetrachloride,
versus the rate constant for
polymerization, in the
particular case of styrene and
carbon tetrachloride, that ratio
was 0.01.
So, if you don't have to worry
about radicals finding
radicals, they're rather dilute,
then the molecular
length will be how likely it is
to react with styrene
compared to how likely it is to
react with carbon
tetrachloride and terminate the
chain.
But that depends on the
concentration of styrene, and
the concentration.
So if you know these two, you
can then work out--
since the transfer reaction with
this process here is only
1% as fast.
So if you had equal amounts of
styrene and carbon
tetrachloride, you'd tend to go
about 100 molecules before
you got a chain transfer.
So you get, on average, about
100 molecular--
100 units in a chain.
If you had more carbon
tetrachloride, you'd get
shorter chains.
If you had less, you'd get
longer chains.
So you can control it, but not
precisely.
There's a property called
dispersity, which is they're
not all exactly the same length,
they're average that,
but some are longer, some are
shorter.
And how wide is this determines
something about,
obviously, the properties of the
material you get.
Ok, we won't go into that any
further.
Now alkene and diene
oligomerization and
polymerization, using carbon
electrophiles
as the active reagents.
Now oligo- means a few, so
oligomerization is putting
just a few such units together.
And so we're going to use either
sigma-star of R with a
leaving group, or R cations as
the reagent to do the
polymerization.
So if you have R+ as an
electrophile, you do a really
interesting reaction.
Notice you can take isobutane
and isobutylene, react them
with H2SO4, and add the elements
of the isobutane, and
I've colored them because you
can do isotopic labeling to
see what's what.
Notice that what added to the
alkene was
this C-H sigma bond.
How do you like that, Noelle?
Can you see any problem with
doing a reaction like that?
What's the HOMO and LUMO of the
purple molecule here?
STUDENT: There doesn't seem to
be any.
PROFESSOR: There's no functional
group there.
How can you do it?
Well, tell me what would happen
first, if you have a
sulfuric acid and react with
this mixture.
What you think would happen
first?
Where is there a functional
group?
STUDENT: 	The pi.
PROFESSOR: The pi bond.
So proton would attack the pi
electrons.
And which end would it attack?
Would you put the proton here,
or would you put the proton on
the more substituted carbon?
STUDENT: It would be
Markovnikov.
PROFESSOR: It would be
Markovnikov. You'd want to get
a t-butyl cation.
OK, so we'll do that.
And incidentally, this product
was not irrelevant,
because that's what they mean
when they say octane.
That compound is defined as 100
octane, for the engine
performance.
So this was being worked on,
during the Second World War,
to try to make high-quality fuel
for airplanes.
OK, so we'll follow what Noelle
says, and
make the t-butyl cation.
And now the t-butyl cation can
react with the
alkene, to give this.
And now you'd say, why don't we
just keep going?
Well, it depends on what the
situation is, and you'll see
it can do that.
But another thing it could do is
react with this.
Watch this.
This is a tertiary cation.
But it's rather hindered.
This one, if you transfer this
with its electrons, curved
arrow there, that's a hydride
shift.
We've seen hydride shifts
before.
The difference is this is
happening between two
molecules, rather than for one
carbon to the next in the
same molecule.
But it was shown by Bartlett in
1944 that this process
happens, using isotopic labels.
So it gives isooctane, and
what's the other product?
What's the purple product?
The H went--
the hydride, not proton,
hydride, the H with its
electrons went up here.
What was left behind?
The t-butyl cation.
But that's what you need here.
So this is a chain, it can go
round and round.
So you add isobutane to
isobutylene.
Now, if you don't have the
isobutane there, then it turns
out that it could do this
polymerization, add another
one and another one, et cetera,
et cetera.
And that gives polyisobutylene,
which is
called butyl rubber.
And it's not a very strong
material, but it has the
virtue of being airtight.
So that's what's made to seal
tires.
When they made inner tubes in
those days, they were made out
of butyl rubber, to hold the air
in.
OK, so now these electrophiles
in terpene and steroid
biogenesis.
Now I'm going to get on to this
next time, but since I
brought stuff here, I'm going to
entertain you
with show-and-tell.
It comes after this set of
slides.
But since I've got it here, I'm
going to do it.
So we'll turn on the light here.
And what I have here, is water
and vinegar, dilute acetic
acid, and this stuff that I
bought down at the art supply
store called mold builder.
But if I read here, it says,
it's ammonia, 100% natural
latex, that means it came right
out of
the tree, and water.
So all that's in there is tree
sap, and water, and ammonia.
So I'm going to pour some into
the water here.
I'm going to take my jacket off
and
tuck my tie in actually.
I think that might be prudent.
OK.
So we're going to open it up
here, and we'll
pour some in there.
OK, now the ammonia keeps the
molecules--
we'll talk about this next time
--
apart from one another of this
latex.
But if we add some vinegar,
it'll get rid of the ammonia.
Obviously I didn't measure it
very carefully.
Oh, there, we're doing it.
So now the molecules are coming
together.
So if I reach in here and grab
it, get rid of that water, dry
it a few times here.
So we've made a rubber ball.
Good.
OK, if anybody wants to make a
rubber ball, you
can come and do it.
Thank you.